welcome to the daily climate show coming
up
power companies are unprepared for the
extreme weather events which climate
change will bring a warning from the
uk's energy regulator
parents call for better climate
education in schools as its revealed
children are turning to social media for
their information
and plans for new zealand attacks cow
and sheep burps in the effort to cut
emissions
[Music]
welcome to the daily climate show where
we track the changes happening to our
planets report on the impact those
changes are having and look for the
search for solutions
well we're in uh negotiations uh with
companies well we're talking first a
little bit about storm arwin
that happened last november now power
companies um are being said that they're
unprepared in the face of extreme events
and obviously that's coming from the
energy
regulator that's off gem because
thousands of people as i said were left
without power for more than a week and
that devastated parts of the country as
i said last winter now off gems chief
executive said energy firms need to be
much better prepared for that extreme
weather which will get more frequent and
intense as the effects of climate change
hit home
we're in negotiation with those
companies about the investment we need
which will include an acceptance that
with climate change there may well be
more extreme weather events there may be
well be more storms and they need to be
better prepared for that but my point is
they weren't good enough this time they
need to use their budgets to fix it and
they need to get ready for this winter
well skye's fraser moored is in county
durham one of the areas worst affected
by storm arwin
there's no doubt that storm irwin was an
extreme weather event here in the
northeast of england it generated winds
gusting up to 98 miles an hour the
strongest for around 30 years or so the
met office said it was one of the most
powerful and destructive storms in a
decade and it caused chaos the road
network the rail networks all disrupted
hundreds of thousands of trees uprooted
and power lines brought down leaving
around a million homes without power
thousands of them for more than a week
hundreds of them for more than two weeks
and today offgen the industry regulator
has criticized some of the electricity
network operators saying that they need
to up their game they need to be better
prepared in case events like this happen
again they need to have better
communication they need to have better
systems of providing compensation for
people in terms of them preparing for
the future many people say they were
ill-prepared for the storms of arwin and
barrow which came shortly afterwards but
it's difficult to predict when these
storms will happen again most people
think that it is because of climate
change but the experts say that that
can't be
empirically proven at the moment the
understanding that we have is that many
weather systems that reach this country
many of the extreme weather systems
start over the atlantic and the earth's
excess heat is stored in our oceans that
heat is what generates the cyclonic
effects which allows storms like this to
take shape in the first place so clearly
it looks as though the climate change
situation does have an impact on these
extreme weather events but it's still
unclear as to exactly what that impact
is and how we can best prepare for the
future
well next children are turning to social
media to learn about climate change
because the topic isn't covered enough
in school now this is by poll by public
first of more than a thousand parents
and they found 50 said climate change
was the most important issue to children
42
of parents said their child had spoken
to them about protecting the environment
most parents said their children should
be taught about climate change and more
than 70 percent wanted their child to
learn about it at school well our
correspondent adele robinson uh joins us
now so adele what education around
climate change is in place at the moment
well there is some but actually um
teachers that particularly the ones who
were spoken to as part of this poll have
said that it's woefully inadequate they
um say that parents believe that their
children is being taught about climate
change and environment and about
environment issues but actually some of
the people spoken to the pupils as well
as the teachers have said that it's been
a year since they've had one single
lesson on
climate change itself climate change
education as well uh has been described
by one senior teacher in this survey as
being a tick box one lesson thing it is
in the curriculum in various aspects
it's in science and geography and in
2025 in three years time there'll be a
new gcse in natural history um and that
will be focusing on protecting the
planet so it's heading in the right
direction but there's not enough right
now is is is the synopsis but there is
this real appetite for it right now and
uh you know teachers are saying that
even if it was introduced the
timetable's already packed there isn't
it's not realistic to fit more in so
they want to see a holistic review of
the curriculum um not just about the
quantity
but also the breadth across the
curriculum in climate change issues and
i suppose my next question then is if
you don't have that climate education in
place what are some of the dangers
people could see
well exactly that there are risks um
because this appetite is huge so there's
an immense enthusiasm among uh school
children they want to learn about this
they've wanted to learn about this more
than any other generation um but what
they're doing is some of them are
turning to online resources which is in
in its entirety isn't necessarily a bad
thing but social media it may be because
they're exposed to misinformation
to bias and it's not the ideal grounding
that you would want for an education in
this subject especially when there's a
fairly large movement out there of
climate change deniers teachers are are
worried that as well if they're getting
their information from social media it
sort of implies that it's just a trend
that they might lose interest they'll
move on to the next thing it needs to be
more in a formal education setting um
the fact though let's focus on the
positives yes they want to know more uh
they're talking to their parents about
this more than anything else i think 13
of parents said their children had
talked to them about immigration 15
brexit but 42 percent were speaking to
them about environment issues and that's
only a good thing so so interesting
adele thank you so much uh well let's
get some of the day's other climate news
now and at least 10 people have died and
three are missing after flooding in
central china around 1.8 million people
have been affected by storms in the
province of hunan since the start of the
month although china often experiences
flooding during the summer the state
media there says some monitoring
stations are reporting historic levels
of rainfall globally more intense
tropical storms are on the rise as a
result of climate change leading to
increased flooding
a vigil has been held outside the
brazilian embassy in london for the
missing environmental journalist don
phillips and his colleague bruno pereira
who went missing in the amazon on sunday
now the pair were on their way back from
a trip to a remote area of the
rainforest home to isolated indigenous
tribes helicopters boats and drones are
now being used
in search of them after local
authorities were criticized for a slow
initial response
in other words world's first zero
emissions commercial hydro foil boat has
been launched by a belfast based
engineering company electric powered
hydro foils hoist the boats above water
using the same technology as developed
by america's cup racing yachts now the
company behind the vessel says its
system is 90 percent more energy
efficient than smaller boats powered
by fossil fuels
now present biden will today use a
promise of economic growth spurred by
clean energy to try and revive a u.s
commitment to latin america which fell
away during the trump administration
opening the summit of the americas in
los angeles last night the president
pledged to help neighboring economies
grow saying investments in renewable
energy would be central to the plan and
later today he's due to meet the
brazilian president john bolsonaro who's
seen as a skeptic on climate change and
he'll then lay out a plan for an
environmentally friendly economic
partnership with other countries across
the region now the biden administration
has put climates at the heart of its
domestic policy plans
the american partnership will tackle the
climate crisis head on with the same
mentality we're bringing to the work in
the united states
when i hear climate
i think jobs
good paying high quality jobs will help
speed our transition
to a green economy of the future
and unleash
sustainable growth
jobs in developing and deploying clean
energy
jobs and decarbonizing the economy
jobs and protecting biodiversity of our
hemisphere
jobs provide dignity of being able to
feed your family
give your children a better life
and envision
a future of possibilities
and finally new zealand has announced
plans to tax cow and sheep bugs new
zealand is home to just over 5 million
people along with 10 million cattle and
26 million sheep and almost half the
country's total greenhouse gas emissions
come from agriculture that's mainly
methane coming from livestock and under
the proposals farmers will have to pay
from 2025 making it the first nation to
charge farmers for the methane emissions
from the animals they keep